[موسيقى]
طبعا هذا حسب النتائج اذا فاز حزب العداله
والتنميه او جبهه اتفاق الجمهوري هذه
سيتطور وسيستمر لكن اذا فاز
اتفاق المله حسب بيانات ناطقيه من عده
احزاب التي تشكل هذه الاتفاقيه وهم يفيدون
بان سياسه التركيه في المنطقه سيتغير 180
180 درجه بمعنى
يتغير
سيتقلص وهم يقولون سننسحب من شمال سوريا
سننسحب من
شمال العراق وما شغلنا بليبيا او حسب
السفير السابق في حزب الجمهوري يقول وجود
تركيا في
في في شرق بحر الابيض هو
استعماري وتوسعه وتجاوزه بمعنى اذا فاز
اتفاق المله سيتقلص وسيتغير يتغير كما
افاده اعلام الغربي بان هذه الانتخابات
نقطه التحول في سياسه المنطقه والعالم
[موسيقى]
اذا فاز
اردوغان كرياسه هذه السياسه سيستمر يمكن
يتطور ستطور لكن على افاده
ناطقي
حزب الاحزاب تابعه لاتفاق المله يقولون
نحن سنكون طرف طرف واحد في جانب في جانب
اوكرانيا ويجب ان نطبق كله
مطلبات الغربيه تجاه روسيا لكن كما نعلم
في العالم رجل الوحيد يمكن يتكلم
يتحدث مع الطرفين بشكل متساوي ويمكن يقدم
اي وقت للوساطه كما كما وضع هذا وساطته في
في قناه
الحبوب لنقل الى العالم عبر
مضيقين التركيين
تركيا دائما جانب المظلمين لكن كما تعلمون
السياسه العالميه لا يريد ابدا اقتراب
وتساعد مع اخوانها العرب ويوجد دائما
مشاكل لوضع
لتفجير هذه العلاقات كما كان في الربيع
مسمى ربيع العربي
[موسيقى]
يصل الصينيه عالميه
لا اعتقد انهم يهتمون كما يهتم به رئيس
اردوغان لكنهم سيدعمون كما دعمه الغربيون
او كما سمحوا الغربيون كما تعلمون هذه
الناطق
السياسه خارجيه
لاتفاق المله
السفير السابق
دائما بياناته
قد
بياناتي قد اعجبت به الغربيون
وبمعنى هذا وهم سيقومون بما سمح الغربيين
لا يريدون ان يكون تركيا مركزا في هذه
المنطقه